you might hurt in this little film
called Fifty Shades of Grey well it's
coming out today and if you haven't seen
the billboards everywhere and the
commercials and all that we're gonna
show you a little bit and then talk
about some stuff to romance my tastes
are very
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right bondage sex humans doing
things that they do
people are going completely crazy
interestingly bondage
sex toys have been selling through the
roof just basically it started with the
book and now it's going into this movie
being released things like leather
paddles blindfolds horsehair floggers
wrist cuffs bondage rope and riding
crops were showing you a few of those
these are from juniors personal
collection right there also according to
the New York Times Benoit balls in
particular have been selling like
hotcakes
let's look at some Benoit balls I'm
unclear as to what the Benoit ball can
either one of you clarify of course
there's a goggle playing to me out there
what they actually are I'll let you guys
explain because I'm not gonna do it but
um it seems once it's inside yeah we're
on the is it is it taking pictures
cameras yeah since we're talking about
being like surveilled by everyone yeah
now your canal yeah we just did a
segment on surveillance so we'll link to
that right here so you know what he's
talking about
I don't think Benoit balls have cameras
in them but I'll tell you how your
cervix is doing yeah exactly
so I like you saw the movie yeah you saw
the movie so without spoiling we don't
do spoilers is there a little bit but
boy is it not interesting at all we
talked about this on what the flick this
week this movie is I don't even know how
to talk about it it's on the one hand
the one interesting idea it has is the
basically it's about a submissive who
out dominance her dominant you know
she's the one really kind of you know
driving the wagon here even though he's
the one who's supposedly in charge but
the movie is much more interested about
dragging him into what it sees as a sort
of conventional conventional normals
than it is about exploring BDSM they
don't really explain it very well
it never looks particularly fun and it
sort of had that it shiz is the idea of
fetish like there's an interest there's
more shots of like his rows of riding
crops in the in the secret Red Room than
there is of them being used you know so
that's it so what do you so without
getting too into the movie since
obviously we haven't seen it what do you
make of when this book came out that
suddenly people felt like they could
talk about this stuff and now the movies
coming out and people are doubling down
and like to me we live at a time where
there's so we're so over sex there's
porn online obviously did you know about
the the porn online what is it it's on
the computer I know you know you're not
being technically downloaded there's
porn in those things but that were so
oversexed already it almost seems silly
to me or something that this movie could
get people excited because all this
stuff is out there if you want to find
out about pretty much anything it's all
out there oh yeah and then I think we're
part of it I don't think it was Louis
Vuitton some leather makers say hey you
know what we'll strap a couple of these
strap ons and balls and I don't know the
hell these things are but um that and
we'll put it with our leather name on it
yeah it'll be everywhere so I mean it's
just it's opportunity and the fact that
we keep missing that is amazing to me
that if I runs up it goes oh yeah I'll
buy one and they go there's something
good there's such a weird culture about
sex yeah you know like yes we all have
the internet and we all have access to
every kind of porn on earth but I think
for a lot of people this is such a taboo
subject and somehow this book these
three books got through to a segment of
the American population that doesn't
talk about the stuff that is and think
about the stuff that never wanted to
explore this stuff and now suddenly is
kind of titillated by it and right I'm
all for people expanding their sexual
horizons of wherever they find it
it doesn't make this these books good
literature doesn't make this a good
movie right but if it if it if it
encourages people to explore their own
sexuality great that's terrific when you
see the Fifty Shades of Grey licensed
merchandise end cap at Target right
which is a real thing that I saw
literally Atari
literally at Target next to the condoms
this end cap of like blindfolds and did
it all with the branded thing it's sort
of like
I guess but you know I you know there
are stores that have more and better
options but you say this is your starter
kit at Target you know not yourself
right so I get I get that like I do get
that like they become so commercialized
I mean that's what you're saying to that
this stuff become so commercialized that
Louis Vuitton's okay putting their name
on this stuff and then it's at Target
but isn't that sort of the point like as
progressives right you're taking it out
of the shadow getting it out of the
shadows and that someone could buy a
freaking whip at Target and throw it in
there thing next to the dog food and
it's like nobody cares because guess
what people are doing this stuff people
won't care I mean that's the okay I get
it and I'd love sexual freedom all for
it now targets are gently community
stores I feel like my target employees
know me yeah you know what in history
they know they know that I buy pull-ups
cuz I have a three-year-old kid like oh
how's the kid they just know where my
killer drive two miles you'll be at
another target no one knows it just
seems like that that's why this
particular stores for yeah yeah that's
why you go to the pleasure just because
they don't necessarily know your name
yeah right if they do they know that
what you buy and that's great yeah so
final thought on this okay fifty shades
of gray it seems to me that naturally
what has to come next is fifty Shades of
gay I'm not brilliant I know but but
that does seem it seems to me that the
next thing that was gonna come out of
the closet no pun intended is get you're
gonna start seeing more gay sex like
that seems to be the next thing like
we've gotten to the point where it
pretty much almost have marriage in all
the country I know we're still working
on twelve states or something but the
next thing is that you're gonna have to
see gay people having some sort of
affection well which they still don't
even do well and move actually here's
here's what the next thing is because
there were two different movies at
Sundance two dealt with this it's about
straight guys in the media allowing
themselves to explore their gay side
without having to claim gay as an
identity we're gonna see more straight
guys in movies and TV like making out
with dudes and more so and not like
being wigged out about it that's the
next frontier you'll be watching that
well you know that's the thing I mean
this is the takeover of the game right
is what I'm trying to convince straight
guys they could make out and then not be
yeah cuz you're hanging says this right
the question you're hanging it we're
looking for you it's for you to rely
acts and calm down because no there's
actually there was a really good
speaking of sentence it was a
documentary there called the mask you
live in that was about how we do such a
crappy job of raising men in this
society because yeah you - shut up their
feelings we don't let them have intimate
friendships with other men and wait at a
time in their life when they eat it
because they're all like no homo so you
know if like if two straight friends
feel like they can confide in each other
about their feelings and like hug each
other occasionally and not have
conniptions about how its somebody's
gonna think they're gay that's only good
right we need to do more segments about
that because this is the same thing
about girls in college they're allowed
to make out with other girls it doesn't
mean there are lesbian Russy a guy
making out with a guy up that's it gay
for life anyway what do you think we
were all over the place there what are
you into sexually
[Music]